[Music]  this is our last new up this is gonna be  the best night of our lives  honey I left an outfit out for you to  wear tonight it sounds great to me oh my  god thank you I'm gonna miss this you  guys are my boys let's make sure we know  remember anything the boys guys there's  something behind you what are you doing  okay I wouldn't put my hand in there  Mandy that's the dumbest idea what do  you think went on down here oh let's get  out of here  [Music]  [Applause]  ha ha very funny guy from the right back  home dude have you ever looked up the  history of this house this guy named  William Sarkin killed 13 people and his  wife so you're saying the house is  haunted  what is that we gotta go no we gonna go  [Music]  you